should president Trump overturn a stupid
Obama era rule banning big-game hunters
from keeping trophies like elephant
tusks as someone with years of
experience seeing pink elephants I will
explain why we need to kill the animals
or else they'll die then Owen Benjamin
and Paula joined the panel of deplorable
z' to talk lascivious leftists at the
New York Times and President Kofi Faye's
latest poetry I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
oh we've got a lot to talk about people
are really misunderstanding this this
Trump error rule on big game trophies
there is just more sex sex sex
that's all that's a news cycle now and
Jacques you'll be surprised it's all
Democrats committing all the all the
crimes but before we get to any of that
we have to get to something at the heart
of all of this which is capitalism
capitalism
we're going to talk a lot about that
today and one thing I really like about
capitalism is it allows me to keep the
lights on here and Marshall employed and
Kofi Fei in my cup because we have a
sponsor we have a sponsor of the show
and this is this sponsor is very near
and dear to my heart this is a special
one it brings a tear to my eye brings
back wistful memories of childhood this
sponsor is mrs. Fields Cookies I did a
call with mrs. fields when they said
they were gonna sponsor the show they
said you know do you think that you can
sell delicious chocolate chip cookies on
your soul well we'll give you a promo
we'll give you a promo code we'll give
you a discount do you think you'll be
able to convince people to eat delicious
mrs. fields chocolate cookies I think
you know I think it'll be a struggle but
you know we'll go out there and and I
think we can do it because you remember
going to the mall as a kid I remember
this I didn't like going to the mall I
don't like shopping or anything but
there was always one great aspect of it
which was mrs. Fields Cookies the smell
of it pervading the entire mall it's all
I wanted to do you'd go now everyone
likes that mrs. fields chocolate chip
cookies they're very delicious they are
what a chocolate chip cookie should be
you remember the smell you remember the
taste for me though I was a little
contrarian as a kid I love the sugar
cookie that's my favorite mrs. Fields
cookie and but they have a ton they have
a lot of options it's probably going to
be your favorite part of holiday
shopping this year and there's there's
just something about that first
delicious bite takes you back to when
you were just a wee little lad or lass
and this holiday seasons you can give
your friends and family that same
feeling of pure joy with a holiday gift
arrangement from mrs. Fields another
great aspect of this is I think I get
some samplers I get some sample cookies
so yeah I'm gonna keep this ad is gonna
be like half the show I think maybe
they'll send me to they've been around
for 40 years mrs. Fields Cookies
everybody knows them everybody loves
them it's not
ready to convince you to eat delicious
chocolate chip cookies they are very
soft they are very chocolatey they're
freshly baked and ready to enjoy right
out of the box so everyone can always
have what they wanted right now now here
is the exclusive deal to my listeners
somehow mrs. Fields Cookies get even
better because they've given us the
promo code cuff fa so that CoV f EF e if
you go to mrs. Fields dot-com right now
you click on the microphone on the upper
right hand corner and you enter the code
cough FA Co V Fe Fe say that ten times
cough FA Cokie gothic cookie cookie Kofi
coffee FA you will get 25% off mrs.
Fields best-selling piece love and
cookies Tim isn't that all we need this
holiday season so you get nibblers
bite-sized cookies brownie bites and
more click on the microphone enter promo
code cough fa at mrs. fields calm yet
the perfect holiday gift for 25% off
that is I'm not an expert at math that's
a quarter of less than the full price
that's almost a quarter it's somewhere
between a third and a fifth so go there
mrs. fields calm right now promo code
cough FA what a great way to start the
week what a great way to start the show
now we have to get you know this gives
you nice images of childhood and that's
really nice now we have to get back into
the news and think about dead elephants
just let's Pleasant that's not as nice
but in any case President Trump is
walking back his administration's
decision to end a three-year-old Obama
era regulation banning big-game hunting
trophies from Africa after a bunch of
people who don't know anything about
big-game hunting or conservation
complained on Twitter even Republicans
even conservatives are getting in on
this because people don't seem to
understand the rationale behind big-game
hunting and trophies here uncle Jimbo
explains we all they kill adults to
quote send out their numbers if we don't
hunt then these animals will grow too
big a number and they won't have enough
food say you see we have to kill animals
or else they'll die there it is it's
simple enough we have to kill the
animals or else they will die that's
very very simple and you know it's it's
comedic right it's so counterintuitive
that hunting the animals will actually
increase their numbers and lead to more
conservation
but just because you don't understand
something doesn't mean it isn't true
shallows are clear right and so the
Atlantic summed up stupid coverage of
this this weekend
they wrote quote if you were an elephant
you might be puzzling over human
behavior this week well I'm not an
elephant also elephants don't puzzle you
know because they're animals but the but
this is how they think right if if I
were the animal if animals were like
people they go further they say if
elephants are recognized as a legal
persons a term the US courts have
granted to corporations well and and New
Zealand has given to a river and it's
been extended to yada yada yada
it would be more difficult to hunt them
at all let alone import their body parts
right so it is true let me try to
explain this to the Atlantic how an
elephant might not be a person but
corporations are people
corporations are are groups of people
they're not groups of animals they're
not buildings they're not newspapers
they're groups of people working in
corporation with one another and you
don't surrender your rights your
constitutional rights just because you
work with other people that's why
famously Mitt Romney he was pilloried
for this but it nevertheless is the case
corporations are people what else are
they they aren't gates they are in
unicorns they are in buildings they're
people they're cooked they're groups of
people working together now here is a
statistic thirty thousand elephants a
year are killed by poachers when we're
talking about big-game hunting and
giving out licenses we're talking about
a handful of these things per year we're
not talking about the thirty thousand
they're killed because their tusks are
so valuable that starving people in
Africa who want to make a profit decide
to kill them and they sell an ounce of
it and they make a year's salary
according to a 2005 paper in the journal
of international wildlife law
legalization of white rhinoceros hunting
in South Africa motivated private
landowners to reintroduce the species
onto their lands so we're not just
talking about in the preserves that are
held by the public or held by the
government or whatever we're talking
about incentives so when this became
legal the landowners realized oh
interesting if we bring some of those
things on here that are worth a ton of
money and we allow people to hunt for
them then we will make money too
as a result there was an increase in
white rhinos from fewer than 100
individual rhinos to more than 11,000
even while only a limited number were
killed as trophies well how does this
work it's because conservation is
expensive so you remember this a couple
years ago in May 2015 a Texan legally
shot a critically endangered black rhino
in Namibia so there's the species of
black rhino they're critically
endangered this guy goes over there and
shoots one he bought a license for
$350,000 that was money generated from
the hunt was a totally managed hunt that
money was reinvested in conservation
maintaining habitats maintaining
environments keeping people around to
stop the poachers and the key here isn't
even the money per se obviously in
Namibia $350,000 goes a long way goes
farther than it does in Los Angeles or
New York but that isn't it's about the
system of incentives just like you know
capitalism as as we describe it and I
don't even like to use that term it's a
term that was invented by socialists to
pillory free markets but freedom
economic freedom free markets protected
by the rule of law and people making
sure there's a level playing field it's
not just about all of the wealth of
producers though it does the reason it
produces that wealth is because all of
the incentives are aligned so if we're
just talking about conservation and only
basing it on altruism there's a limit to
human altruism but there isn't a limit
to human humans looking after their own
interests and hopefully producing good
along the way meaning property meaning
prosperity meaning jobs for people
meaning wealth to invest in the
environment we'll talk about this a
little bit more on Thursday when we get
to Thanksgiving but the pilgrims learn
this lesson very hard after a couple
years incentives are important here so
for instance when this big-game hunting
is illegal when trophies can be taken
home then there's more of an incentive
to have wild land and less farmland so
it keeps the wild wild why is this
well if land owners can make more money
either the government or private land
owners can make more money from selling
licenses and letting people hunt these
beautiful animals than they can from
farming then they're going to do that
right but
but if they start farming then they're
gonna cut down all of the grazing
habitats anyway so controlled legalized
hunting has also been beneficial for
Zimbabwe elephants now that this is the
big issue people love elephants I love
elephants it's the symbol of my dear
political party where elephant designs
and things like that for just that
reason there are those weird videos of
elephants painting that are very
terrifying you know they're clearly they
exhibit some intelligence so they say
well if we allow this these trophies
then you know then the elephants are
going to be endangered and all of their
tusks are going to be taken and sold for
the ivory but trophy hunting has doubled
the area of that country under wildlife
management relative to the 13 percent in
state protected areas why is that
because there's incentive incentive for
wild areas to remain wild as a result
the area of suitable land available to
elephants and other wildlife has
increased and by the way we're not
talking about post hunt sales so we're
not saying well there will be more and
there will be a freer market and trading
in these things so poachers are just
gonna go out and get them and sell them
there first of all they're already doing
that poaching is the problem these
big-game hunters are statistically
insignificant when we're talking about
big-game elephants rhinoceroses being
killed but we're not even talking about
post on sales we're talking about
trophies so you have to hunt it you have
to get it you have to bring it home you
can't buy it from a poacher it doesn't
change that market whatsoever now
talking just about rhinos two rhinos per
day were killed in Africa in 2012 well
over 700 Africa's there is 700 rhinos
South Africa alone 461 rhinos were
killed in just the first half of 2013
South Africa is a major area for this so
we know that that's the problem the
problem is an Eric Trump going and
hunting or some dentist from America or
a guy who purchases a very expensive
permit to go to conservation efforts
it's difficult for lefties to consider
these things beyond the the graphic even
some conservatives have fallen into this
I saw a lot of famous right-wing
celebrities I won't name them because
their allies and they're usually right
but they were wrong about this saying
this is awful Donald Trump you have to
get rid of this is so terrible but it
you know shallows or clear folks
very often you know you see the picture
you see the poor little rhinoceros or
the animals or the cheetahs and you say
we shouldn't do that but your gut
emotional visceral reaction is not
necessarily the way to protect these
animals it isn't enough to say not that
one oh look we saved sessile isn't that
okay don't worry everything's fine now
Cecil isn't the issue the issue is
30,000 hours this being killed every
year the issue is or poachers because
these these trophies have value to them
and the challenge is to stop being
emotional - stop saying well as long as
we don't see any more pictures that's
all well and good you have to think
beyond the pictures and think about
creating incentives and systems that
will actually protect those animals so
as a result I hope that President Trump
thinks about this thoughtfully and
doesn't simply listen to all of the
people on Twitter because people on
Twitter very often don't know a thing
let's bring on our panel to debate this
we are blessed today we have His
Eminence Paul Cardinal Bois and
excellent comedian Owen Benjamin thank
you both for being here what's up guys
oh and thank you for your first
appearance on the panel of deplorable so
I appreciate it before we get into the
news there is so much sex in the new the
news is just all sex basically and then
a little bit of Twitter before we get
into that we I want to keep talking
about this elephant thing a little bit
am I totally crazy here am I just like
the arch-conservative who is contrarian
about everything including poor
suffering elephants and rhinos Owen
should Donald Trump reverse this
three-year-old Obama era rule banning
the importation of these trophies no
because if you are if you care about the
animals you know that that the
conservation comes from the money that
hunters spend on these uh on the animals
my uncle hunts in Africa three times a
year and when you uh when you allow
trophy hunting that will pay for the
conservation efforts to get rid of
poachers yeah well that's the issue and
I think the issue is we don't want to
talk about the poachers because we only
want to talk about the mean wealthy
white Americans who go over and shoot
mr. Bois you're a you're a Shiite
Catholic is there
you know Pope Francis has been very
forceful about saying that we need to
protect the environment and global
warming is a big issue and you know we
need to protect dear sister Earth is
there a Catholic or a Christian or
religious argument for not shooting
these animals and thereby saving them
well for me when it comes to I mean I
certainly have a philosophical and
theological bent I mean when it comes to
hunting I would say I mean if you plan
on eating the animal then go ahead and
hunt it come to the trophy hunting I
mean I'm not very privy towards that I
mean I haven't fully seen the full
theological and moral explanations of it
as we can because we have dominion over
the earth and the sea well yeah I mean
in terms of just just killing an animal
just for fun and for sport and just
display it on your wall I mean that's
not necessarily something that I myself
am a fully gung-ho about but at the same
time typical hippie claptrap from Paul
blah I'm sorry I cut you off
you as you laid out in your piece I
certainly think that when it comes to
big-game hunting like this I see no
reason to issue a full ban on it I think
if we didn't it would just succumb to
poaching and I actually think more
animals would die as a result of it I
think the bigger thing to talk about
here is and Matt Walsh laid this out on
The Daily wire is the left's obsession
and I would call an animal worship of
crying about elephants and lions being
killed as we're slaughtering unborn
children here in the United States and
that's really the the just the the total
irony of all this is that the left you
know throws up in arms over a couple
elephants or rhinos
I mean Cecile Richards this is the irony
over the weekend
Cecile Richards while Al Franken is
getting accused of sexual harassment she
doesn't say anything about him but she's
you know lamenting about Trump lifting
the ban on big-game hunting in Africa
completely unaware of the fact that
their organizations killing 350,000
unborn children a year so that's the
that's the real big to
and the best is that combination of
these lefties the vegan socialist who
says we need to protect every single
organism except for innocent human
babies and says that we should have no
free markets whatsoever except in
trading baby parts from Planned
Parenthood there are some contradictions
one seems at the one seems to think at
the heart of their their thesis now Owen
your family hunts if Teddy Roosevelt
personally former president went and
bagged like five hundred of these big
game in Africa has America gone soft why
is the attitude we have to change so
much well and and to go off your other
point it's all ironic because if you
like elephants you save elephants with
these laws that let hunters hunt them
that's the irony it's not even about
saving elephants because if you want to
save elephants you would charge hunters
an exuberant amount of money to go shoot
one and bring home tusks because then
that money pays for the protection of
the animals so if you're looking for a
net gain in elephant population you will
support hunting I live in a State Park
and I live in the Adirondack Mountains
in New York and so the best conservation
method is charging people to see
something beautiful because then that'll
pay for people to protect it that's
right the free market incentive model is
the only way to protect anything if
you're relying on people's goodwill and
saying I just donate and whatever you
know that's that might not be the most
reliable but you know people are gonna
want to see beautiful things and you
need to align incentives so that that
works absolutely right but it gets to
that point it isn't about saving the
elephant's it isn't about saving the
rhinoceros it's about feeling good about
ourselves it's just about it's just a
blood performing virtue so that when we
go to cocktail parties is oh did you see
that awful what Trump did with the with
the licenses oh yes well I was just
terrible wasn't it and they do it on the
sex stuff too this brings us to one of
the finest stories today the
insufferable New York Times White House
correspondent delenn thrush has said of
sexual harassment allegations against
fellow journalist Mark Halperin quote
young people who come into a newsroom
deserve to be taught our trade given our
support and enlisted in our calling not
betrayed by little men who believe
they're bigger than the mission you know
the mission of the New York Times to
spread fake news one assumes but maybe
he thinks there's a different mission
now turns out he's completely full of it
her allegations against him one woman
writes five years ago and thrush and I
were colleagues at Politico I was in the
same bar as ocassi OHS friend perhaps
the same booth he caught me off guard
put his hand on my thigh started kissing
me he pressured one woman who went into
a cab crying apparently three young
women who were interviewed including
this woman who writes about her
experience in the cab described a range
of similar experiences from unwanted
groping and kissing to wet kisses out of
nowhere too hazy sexual encounters that
played out under the influence of
alcohol and they all explained that they
were scared violated ashamed weirded out
and the woman who wrote this piece that
I wasn't am angry then it turns out to
rush when the women would turn down his
advances he would disparage them in the
newsroom and try to hurt their careers
he has now been suspended which is quite
nice Al Franken is also in more trouble
he's accused of copping a feel
during photos at the State Park he
basically denied this he said I take
thousands of photos at the State Fair
surrounded by hundreds of people I don't
remember taking that picture I feel
badly if the woman came away feeling
disrespected now the woman and her
husband they say I was upset I wasn't
happy in the least he was already gone I
wasn't gonna confront him but I was in
shock that's a Democrat senator said she
feels gross wanted to wash it off of her
the best I think of all of these is a
writer on the HBO show girls Marie
Miller has been accused of rape by an
actress as a serious allegation so what
did lena dunham do the [ __ ] the creator
of girls she called the self-identified
rape victim a liar that's what lena
dunham feminist lenny letter that's what
she said quote one of the three percent
of rapes misreported every year that's
it how do we know because we shouldn't
believe the victims she tweeted in
august however quote things women do lie
about what they ate for lunch things
women don't lie about
seems she's changed her mind because
it's now affecting her show and her
friend now I want to get into this there
is there is so much here to talk about
but before we can talk about all the
weird sexual deviancy of the Democratic
Party I have to say goodbye to you dear
Facebook and YouTube to those who are
already subscribing thank you appreciate
it you helped put the light on you
helped me get mrs. Fields Cookies
samplers to those of you who don't go
over to the Daily wire calm right now
now what do you get we've been talking
about capitalism all day you get all
those ads that are on the website they
go away you get me you get the inter
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
yeah yeah yeah you get this and this is
really important this is really
important now that Glen thrush has been
suspended at the New York Times
now that Lena Dunham is on defense with
sexual assault you need this leftist
here's tumblr it's gonna save your life
it's gonna save the life of you and your
family because otherwise you could you
never know when a flood is gonna strike
if you don't have homeowners insurance
it could destroy your house just get the
leftist here's a tumblr that's insurance
enough I think from floods I
it will keep your leftist here's hot or
cold always salty and delicious go to
daily wire calm right now we'll be right
back
[Music]
I actually wasn't sure on this story if
the Democrats are just being cynical and
deceptive or if really they're ignorant
you know Lena Dunham here is making me
think it's the former mister Bois do
they have any credibility on this issue
is it stupidity or is it malice I'm
gonna go with malice here and I know
especially with Lena Dunham III I think
I don't necessarily know Lena Adams a
full relationship to this particular
situation but my my guess is that the
second one of the people in her circles
was accuse of rape she immediately said
okay that's gonna reflect badly on me I
have to immediately get out there and
see if I can do enough damage control
and discredit this accuser fast enough
and hopefully it will go away but I
think she quickly realized that that was
a very very bad move and now she's she
swung it the other way if you notice
what she said in her apology she didn't
even just come out and say you know I I
made a mistake I reacted too badly you
know I was just harsh you know I know
this person and I was just trying to be
a good friend or something she she comes
out and she immediately says oh as a
true feminist we need to make sure that
like every single time a woman comes
forward they are automatically a
believed automatically believe so
essentially she takes it from completely
discrediting a rape victim to saying
that no matter what we should believe
anybody that comes forward rape so just
create a precedent so just create a
false allegation and and somebody
innocent could pen dependent really die
so yeah I think somebody innocent could
potentially have their lives ruined so
I'm gonna call malice yeah it's a nice
little dance that she does because she
she gets to defend her friend and defend
her show and call this woman a liar and
then once that passes she does a little
little Lena Dunham two-step and now says
oh but actually we should do exactly the
opposite of why I did what I did and I
have credibility to tell you that
because I am the voice of feminism I am
the voice of my generation and it's it
is this total this is the essence of the
left
they want the appearance of the thing
but they don't want the essence of the
thing they want the appearance of taking
sexual assault very seriously but then
they'll support Bill Clinton they'll
support al Frank and they'll support
their showrunner they're their writer on
their show who is accused of rape
they'll support anybody because that's
that's just the thing itself what really
matters is the appearance you know it's
not a thing it's it's that greater truth
that their complete lie that they're
promoting is is supposedly getting at
now to be devil's advocate here oh and
politicians have always been dogs
they've always cheated on their wives
they've been the sort of the scum of the
earth if Madison in Federalist 51
basically explains Congress as a place
to put all of the sociopaths so that
they can counter each other and keep one
another busy and not destroy the entire
country so knowing all of that should we
really force people like Franken to
resign for doing what politicians have
always done well I think just to add on
your on your last point I think the left
is the first to stand up for something
and then the first to sit down I I mean
I know why these people and Lena Dunham
is the product of what happens when you
give a comedian Fame based on pushing a
political agenda and not being funny
what they do is they go for applause not
laughter and then when they ask themself
what is the right answer it's not it's
nothing to do with ethics it has to do
with what will give me more applause and
in one minute it's saying everybody who
claims rape is a victim the next minute
you have to say the opposite but in
their mind it's just about power
acquisition not about living a
principled life so they will change
constantly and the male feminists are
just like don't fall asleep around a
male feminists if you're a woman because
they're so self-hating you can't
possibly trust them and thank you so
much I I do think male feminists or the
creepiest people on planet earth never
near any other they are this has been
your observation too and obviously there
are a lot of scandals to that effect
hitting comedy specifically right now
yeah and like I lost my agent and God I
lost a gig at a college because I said
three-year-olds can't be transgendered
because there was some it's just kidding
absurd it's like nd onion wouldn't be
able to do this Marshall did you you can
my show are you telling me to you I
can't believe you would book such a sick
vicious month so you you've got okay oh
and you're trying to tell me that little
toddlers can't decide that they're the
other gender and then completely destroy
their bodies with drugs right and I was
arguing with someone on Twitter this guy
Jesse thorne who has like a pretty big
following blue checkmark that whole
thing but I and and I was getting the
the sense that I had to back down on
this and I'm like I'll die on this hill
yeah we're not gonna pump a kid for
hormones like what's wrong with you guys
I got I'll like go down the lazy river
on a couple of these things because I
don't you want to but not when it comes
right but then I was like I'll get
another job if I have to agree to
basically turning a kid into a eunuch
and castrato in the early 20th century
and now they're making a swing back they
were going for a hundred years we're
doing it to kids again yeah and I think
with stuff like Franken I think a lot of
the nation wants their head they want
him to resign because you're right like
like like that old quote that you were
talking about how uh Washington is full
of sociopaths and and these people are
just a snake pit you know but at the
same time when you have someone that's
promoting such false virtue you uh you
want to see them burn when you realize
that they're hypocrites I think that I
think making a mistake like train wrecks
are a lot more forgivable than
hypocrites and I think dudes like Frank
and have been so outspoken about how sis
white males are the devil and you know
American capitalism and America as a
nation is somehow bad and we should bow
down to you know these elements of
socialism and Marxism that I think when
when they're revealed to be just slimy
perverts we just want them to look at
their own mirror and say sorry which
they never will so they just have to go
yeah that's a totally fair point and the
the sly meanness of male feminists and
soy boys and all of that is really
frustrating I love to your distinction
between the comedians who are going at
and can actually get laughs and the ones
who need to supplement their laughs with
applause I got
what my favorite comedian my favorite
living comedian is Norm Macdonald and I
see him whenever I can he's he's so good
his book is so good and heat man went so
good when he plays live every word every
syllable out of his mouth is designed to
move you closer to a laugh
he describes comedy like dancing comedy
is to make a noise out of your audience
and he's also brilliant he makes great
points but it's all about the comedy do
you think it's because some of these
comedians just aren't that talented so
they're cheating or do you think
something about that culture of comedy
and entertainment is making is
incentivizing all this virtue signaling
I think it's the culture I think that
like there's some comedians that I've
watched be pretty good turn into
absolute garbage like Trevor Noah
his first hour special there's some
funny stuff in it and now he's literally
a propagandist like there's no laughter
and Jon Stewart you know I don't agree
with his politics but he would make me
laugh because at least he's being a
comedian that's why I made that video
why I hate the left on YouTube if you
guys want to check it out it it makes a
distinction between just liberals how I
always thought they were you know just
bigger government and then leftist which
I now think so many more liberals are
becoming which is just this post
modernist nothing matters and promoting
just this weird self-hate of our country
and culture and I think that really good
comics a lot of times get blackballed
from Hollywood because laughter
terrifies authoritarians and people that
are trying to get rid of individual
autonomy that is a tremendously good
point and and I hadn't occurred to me
that that's what's so scary about comedy
is a political weapon and as a weapon in
the culture it's kryptonite like I'll do
a video in Corpus Christi all Hispanic
and do a joke that one of these leftist
would would say makes me racist and
you'll watch like rednecks and and
Mexicans just dying laughing together
and that terrifies people that are
trying to put us into demographic voting
pools because it shows that their entire
premise is flawed that we are in
individuals and we aren't defined by
race gender all that stuff and and when
I do male/female jokes and you see women
buckled over laughing it's a lot harder
to say that I'm a sexist for saying
there are differences between men and
women right and so you know it's true
they're like they're obviously like
they're living as it's true
exactly and then when you watch someone
like Colbert also make that transition
of being funny in that character and now
being uh almost like a a weird preacher
you know like at that moment with call
me when he's like Trump fires call me
and they applaud and then he's like but
wait no we don't want that and then they
applaud the next point it's like no one
even knows what they believe Stephen
Colbert is an even more obtuse dick
cavett which is an achievement but it is
insufferable to watch and that the
comedy in politics this does make me
think about the exuberance behind the
the Trump election the Trump campaign
and the movement had spawned I just
could go through three of my favorite
tweets from the weekend and maybe we can
talk about the poetic diction of those
the first one from from El Presidente
president cough F a quote Marshawn Lynch
of the NFL's Oakland Raiders stands for
the Mexican anthem and sits down to boos
for our national anthem great disrespect
next time NFL should suspend him for
remainder of season attendance and
ratings way down it's a love that
they've expanded that up to 280
characters on Twitter we're getting a
lot more coach Fame he goes on he says
now that the three basketball players
are out of China and saved from years in
jail
Lavar ball the father of Lee Angelo is
unaccepting of what I did for his son
and the shoplifting is no big deal I
should have left them in jail and then
my favorite is came over the weekend
crookedy Hillary Clinton is the worst
and biggest loser of all time she just
can't stop which is so good for the
Republican Party Hillary get on with
your life and give it another try in
three years
absolutely absolutely brilliant before
it's all filling a void I want to end
this on a
high note I want to end this Owen with
you explaining to me why this is great
but before that I do want to check in
with Paul Cardinal Bois is there
anything undignified about this sort of
humor one word Michael nope good and
here's why you know this is one of the
greatest things about me out me being a
Catholic and you know the thing is well
the best is the heaven I guess yeah but
after that seconds man well one of the I
mean I guess reliefs about being a
Catholic in this modern age is that you
know what the presidency is not my
papacy and therefore I don't look at it
as this like perfectly like clean place
where the president always has to be
this just like perfect bright shining
example of everything that is wonderful
and decent and you know because I
because what a lot of never Trump errs
will say is that you know if people in
the culture are acting badly and acting
wrong objectively wrong the president
should just shut up and let them do it
and run all over us and I say no I say
absolutely not UCLA players go to a
foreign country they steal and then they
could end up in jail in China for ten
years and then the their dad is gonna be
a jerk about it on on national news I
say absolutely do it you know good on
president Trump for that good on
President Trump for blasting NFL for
kneeling before the national anthem I
absolutely say go out do it you know I
mean that's why we elected him so I'm
totally on board
it is great your traitorous dual
allegiance to your king in Rome does
give you a pretty good perspective on
this civil religion people love the
Civic religion they treat the president
like he's a divine monarch or like he's
a divine figure but no he's just a
politician and we can laugh at them Owen
is Donald Trump the funniest president
in the history of the United States
he's definitely up there I mean and I
think give you that but good to tap-tap
was funny but is usually just physical
comedies and think that it's like the
bathtubs
let's or something yeah Lincoln was a
prop comic that hat was just total stick
it's carrot tub came in the vein of
Abraham Lincoln the first time that
statements ever been uttered do you find
that this comedy I mean it's really
entertaining is Donald Trump using it
intentionally does he understand how
effective his language is it seems to me
he does and why can't the left get it
why is the left so weak and so
vulnerable to this form of right-wing
humor well I think he's feeling like as
a businessman he's filling a niche that
has just been so unnaturally vacated
which is uh met just men like you like I
think in this world of how you know men
are just seen as toxic and manspreading
and mansplaining and you know we have to
hire women for jobs even if a man smart
or like men are just like I want someone
to talk like a man talks and scold
people when they do something stupid and
not have to act like everything everyone
does that isn't male it's just brilliant
when it isn't and I think that trumps
just clear language is very very
refreshing to a lot of people and a lot
of people that don't want to admit it
either I mean I have liberal friends
that I I've watched them see Trump say
something and they instinctively laugh
and that's why laughter so terrifying to
authoritarians cuz like I look at him
like you know that's funny
and you know that like Hillary is
crooked and now that Donna Brazil's
books out make it showing that it's even
worse than a lot of people thought you
know just to have this guy just speak
very plainly and not demonize um
especially white males you know my white
work the worst of the worst the villains
of history right right oh sorry go ahead
oh you go ahead there there is this
reason that crook had stuck to her I
love that crooked Hillary thing people
laugh at it he had tried a few others he
tried no stam and a Hillary or this or
that but the recent crooked stuck to her
is cuz it's true the reason his comedy
works
the reason comedy in general works is
when it's true when it's pointy
add something and you know people always
say well he's saying what we're all
thinking or it's funny because it's true
I love you let me think you know I
published this blank book at the
beginning of the year by the way Black
Friday is coming up the most important
gift to give to all of your Democrat
friends and relatives is the
presidential endorsed number one
international best-selling political
dome reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide which is completely
blank of course and all the reactions I
got from Democrats a number of magazines
called Esquire called and left-wing
magazines and they said that's not funny
when I went it reminded me of that meme
on the internet of Sandra Fluke the the
total Democrat contrivance who had the
sacramental view of birth control
and she would say hmm that's not funny
you know and her arms were crossed that
reminds me of them but can the left
reclaim humor at all or is it never lost
they're done with that because it's just
they're so not set in reality and and
comedy has to be set in reality that's
what makes it special where you you say
something and you make people laugh
because they're like that is true and if
you time it properly it's like music you
know and and the left is so just diluted
at this point that like the Overton
Window or just went off the cliff right
so there's just no there's no more
comedy coming from those guys you know
there's no stalingrad funny bone cuz
there's no there's no objective space
there's no there's no common space where
that you know obviously if comedy is the
kryptonite to the totalitarians they are
the totalitarian so you know they're
probably not gonna put it out but
there's no there's no point because
their vision of the world is so
distorted it has become so warped and
the thing that you got knocked for you
lost your representation because you
said that toddlers shouldn't have
hormones injected into them to make them
eunuchs that they think that that would
be that's the appropriate that's a
socially just and progressive thing to
do shows that their vision of the world
is so distorted it's it's that's the the
the perfect encapsulation of it and so
you can't be funny you got to be real if
you're gonna be
that's what that's what makes people
laugh alright guys they walk all right
sorry one more final word oh no I could
just talk about comedy theory all day so
you got to cut me off at some point all
right I got to cut you off I'm gonna
bring you back on to talk about it
because we are in a moment of
conservative cultural exuberance and
comedy and we should we should enjoy it
because for a long time the left tried
to dominate that realm and now they're
just to quote Sandra Fluke they're not
funny when we're okay guys thank you for
being here comedian Owen Benjamin Paul
Cardinal Bois His Eminence himself that
is our show today
get ready I've got a fun Thanksgiving
show coming up so you can send in all
your questions about why the lefties are
completely wrong about Thanksgiving and
I'll try to fit them in and make sure
you listen to another kingdom my show
with Andrew Clavin it's Andrew clavin's
latest story a narrative about a 30 year
old Hollywood schlub who walks through a
portal into another Kingdom and he is
the murder suspect with ogres and
daggers and damsels and it's got a
gazillion views if you could help us get
even more leave a review and subscribe
and send it to your friends we might
force it down hollywood's throat and
that would give me great great pleasure
until tomorrow
i'm michael Knowles's the Michael Doyle
show come back tomorrow we'll do it all
again
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer mathis Glover
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jeshua alvera and our associate producer
is Bailey Lynn the Michael Noel's show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017